as vladimir putin prepares to invade
ukraine it's more important than ever to
show our enemies around the world that
the west is strong
united and ready to fight for our
position of global leadership
yes it was embarrassing when a bunch of
illiterate goat herders stole all our
military gear and chased us out of
afghanistan last year and yes
it's not a great look
that
neither american political party
reliably trusts the results of our
elections and okay fine it is
unfortunate that we no longer have a
functioning national border and that
violent crime is surging from coast to
coast and that our population is
literally dying through drugs and
suicide and sterility with no end in
sight
but
but
putin should not mistake any of those
problems for western weakness no sir
just look at our next generation of
leaders
i'm talking about the ivy league
where over the weekend a young swimmer
performed dazzling record-breaking
historic feats of athleticism at the
women's swimming and diving
championships
there
a young woman whose birth certificate
reads will thomas
won the 100 yard freestyle
the 200 yard freestyle and the 500 yard
freestyle
setting five individual records and
pushing all the other gals on pens 400
relay team to set a pool record
yes
just one look at will thomas's maidenly
adam's apple shimmering as
she
glided toward the finish line should
send a shiver down vladimir putin's
spine
the way that her
hulking feminine shoulders plowed
through the water easily overtaking the
other young ladies should strike fear in
the heart of russia's leader the very
words our civilization is strong seemed
to sing from thomas's big
square
delicate jawline as he took women's
sports to new heights in the very heart
of the american elite
no
no no western civilization is not
finished we're just transitioning i'm
glad you liked that clip now
this is important
ring that bell
subscribe you'll get notifications you
can also head on over to apple podcast
spotify stitcher google play wherever
you get your audio podcast subscribe to
the michael knowles show leave a 5 star
review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]